remplie serge ce que je savais pas c'est
que ton père des pianistes à l'étoile
s'apprête ainsi à pigalle à belleville
ouais il est même un vincent 70 aux
enfants elle chante ça c'est pour ça que
taper la chanson comme ça quand habitait
rue chaptal en face de la sacem c'est un
sim et bien et du club et du hot club de
france et tu rencontré fréhel dans les
rues et je suis revenu sur ma barrows à
la croix d'honneur et réalité à partir m
a payé
et vous connaît et elle que ce qu'elle
sans moyens qu'il dort je pense qu'on
est à fait deux chansons avant de faire
le poinçonneur c'était nul ne le saura
jamais mais ça ne vaut pas la peine non
et ça devrait bien passer dans souviens
dans les yéti's sont prémonitoires si
nul ne le saura jamais et ça ne vaut pas
la peine d'en parler
et après tu as fait le poinçonneur en 64
affectés à des capucines c'était avec
boby lapointe et ça s'était passé comme
en bas c'est lui qui celui-ci qui a
ravagé tard
qu est ce qu a influencé moi y apparaît
sur les mots il ya un plan c non c'est
bien
école ouais en 79 café le palace savoie
ils s'aimèrent rappelle des souvenirs
avec la wii avec nous rasta et choristes
de marle et les chanteurs de tous les
rôles en barre il devait aragon ouais
mais pas calice il aura tué seriak des
moeurs
on a toujours là d'accord en 85 casino
de paris
c'était un peu la dernière nathalie
c'est la dernière fois que je fais de la
scène
non pour moi non je veux pas nous faire
le coup des études mais un tu vas pas
nous faire les adieux tous les ans c'est
pour les agneaux celle ci voilà tu nous
fais les élites de gainsbourg s'asseoir
dans tous les formats ca total